peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'étais je m'étais promis de vous
dire pour commencer une très courte
fable une petite fable de la fontaine
c'est tout le monde connaît fat en laine
de fallout 9 mon auteur favori le corps
barré de renou le robot le barbeau d'un
corner nuque le corner on se regarde je
ne mangeais pas voulu le jeu vous en
dire une autre toujours de ta font
toujours de fa temps devenu du même
auteur le coche et malouche et ma douche
le moche et s'accrochant avec le junior
maintenant oui je me rends bien compte
que je baille ouf c'est de la bouffe je
la fouille de la bafouille latéralement
bafoue unités marland militairement
je me rends j'aimerais vous dire
franchement je m'attendais pas à
entendre en arrivant à voir tant de
monde devant voient leur temps demandant
tout autour de toi que tu autour me dois
au tourne mais même dernier roi humaine
dernière merde t'es même mais pour ça
que j'ai la funky gorge j'ai là là on
défie cloche la langue si je peux plus
utiliser des mots
pierre petitguillaume et ppr petit mulot
halimi je vais vous le dire en anglais
aie aie aie aie aie aie aie aie aie aie
catherine ailleurs le stream butte aux
cailles aux missions ariane full of
eichmann a fait mouche en dessous si
ceux ci sont mes peines ni paul tout six
copines à paul sommet n'était pas le
fils mort be be more by forme j'aurais
dû le dire en japonais je savais c'est
pour ça je ne voulais pas venir l'avais
dit je l'avais d'immigrés du chai à
michel degrés avec sim elle a su mer
hachée ou pas trop je viens unis non ne
me forcez pas il m'a dit mais si allons
mener vers 8h30 ou prendrait la pire on
veut vous prendrai la parole je le lui
ai dit moi les deux formats
vous le connaissez fister insisté
tellement insisté alors moi je voulais
montrer qu'à l'occasion je trouvais
qu'ils ferment également déjà rués gaga
est gâteux gars savaient que ces
terribles à fait pareil
infi roda paye 1 0 ap un défaut comme ça
vous ne voudriez pas que c'est ça qui
m'a fait rater mon deuxième mariage mon
deuxième run in my avant le troisième
d'ailleurs et pourtant je donne ma
parole d'honneur ma fille sonia était
mal de fois et cette méfiance était
vraiment mort folle de moi
moi je n'étais mots furent où la foudre
ou en amoureux vous fout oui oui on a
rien à faire et c'est comme ça depuis ce
matin
comme le matin du jour de mes fils en y
demeurant fin demain mon mariage mariage
raté
d'ailleurs dès le matin j'avais eu un
mauvais c'est promis temps ça j'ai un
mauvais point de vente y sent vraiment
si tu m'en douter quand je me suis levé
j'ai vu une araignée qui ont été durcies
tranier du gratin machin a régné du chat
live harrison c'est pas la peine j'ai
appris dans les rangs j'avais prévenu
après j'y arriverai jamais exki mézois
excuses que mezouar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]